pokemon has ballooned into an incredible
essential franchise you simply can't
imagine what your life would have been
like without it particularly in the
early gen 1 days of the red and green
versions or blue version for those of us
outside of japan there are many minor
interesting details about pokemon that
fans may not know or have forgotten
about despite many infamous exploits
like the missing number glitch so here
are 10 pokemon things that you might not
have known about pokemon if you want
more pokemon sub to this channel as the
latest game legends arceus is fast
approaching and will have plenty of
coverage when it releases
one of the best parts of playing pokemon
whether it's the video game or the card
game is the concept of collecting as
much as you can there are hundreds of
different pokemon species just waiting
to be caught so it makes sense that the
inspiration for pokemon also came from a
similar hobby insect collecting that's
right the original concept of the
pokemon came from satoshi tajiri one of
the creators of game freak and his hobby
of insect collecting as a child combined
with the fascination of the gameboy's
link cable he even described imagining
little bugs crawling through the cables
between game boys at one point
when deciding which platform to develop
pokemon on the gameboy's link cable was
the deciding factor for todri fueled by
a frustrating encounter with the dragon
quest 2 item on the famicom tajiri
desperately wanted a hard to find item
from dragon quest and try to find a way
to acquire the item from fellow pokemon
creator ken sugamori who happened to
have two but to no avail since the
famicom had no way to connect two games
thus we have the inspiration for
utilizing the gameboy's link cable to
trade pokemon with friends nintendo at
first couldn't grasp the concept of
using the link cable to trade
collectibles or the appeal of pokemon in
general still they trusted tajiri's game
development reputation and decided to
give it a shot the rest as they say is
history
most fans of pokemon know that pokemon
is short for pocket monsters indicated
by trainers stashing away pokeballs
they've used to catch any given pokemon
in their literal pocket what's less
known is that this wasn't tajiri's first
choice for the name instead he hoped to
call the game capsule monsters but ran
into trademark issues shortening capsule
monsters to capmon didn't quite hit the
same mark either and the name eventually
found a home in pokemon
alright if i were to ask you which
pokemon was first created maybe you'd
say pikachu since pikachu is arguably
the most recognizable pokemon of all
time or you might say bulbasaur since
its national pokedex number is literally
zero zero one arguments can also be made
for charizard or venusaur as the covers
for red and green but in actuality the
first pokemon designed was ride-on ride
on might not be number one of the
national decks but according to ken
sugimori its internal id number is one
it makes sense too since you'll see the
ride on sprite a lot throughout gen 1
whether in pokemon gym statues or as
sprites for other pokemon when in your
team menus
one of the most iconic secrets was mew a
pokemon after the legendary mewtwo to
fully appreciate how incredible the
mythical mew was you had to be a kid
growing up in the mid 90s honestly mew
was like this playground folklore
something you'd hear about at the park
and it added to the mystique of gen 1.
the way mew was integrated into the
cartridge is just as surprising because
nintendo had no clue since game freak
simply popped mew in at the very end of
the development process mew couldn't be
found in the game without exploiting a
glitch or cheating but that didn't stop
trainers from doing what they needed to
do to catch mew and add it to their team
eventually mew was distributed to select
few trainers officially and a growing
trend of special events were established
in future games players would gather at
these events and get special mystery
gift pokemon or items many of which
included mythical pokemon like mew
arguably one of the biggest positives of
playing gold silver and crystal is that
the gen 2 games let you explore kanto
from gen 1 after you became champion as
a kid this was an incredible experience
before ending in a climactic battle
against red in mount silver what fans
probably don't know is that the kanto
region almost didn't make the cut in gen
2 after all kanto is a vast region which
means a lot of data for the game boy
hardware cramming both johto and kanto
onto the same cartridge was no small
task it was nearly impossible that is
until satoru iwata who later became the
president of nintendo showed gamefreak a
way to compress the data to be
manageable there are story implications
for why kanto appears sparse in certain
areas but we have a technical
explanation as well which is why areas
like viridian forest are dramatically
different in gen 2. either way game
freak owed a lot to mystery iwata and
there's even a heartwarming easter egg
later an ultra moon and ultra sun
referencing mr iwata's role during gen
2's development
the game corner is notorious for several
reasons especially in gens 1 and 2. for
starters it posed as team rocket's
original hideout in celadon city that
same game corner was also the only way
to get a porygon in the game for a cool
9999 coins but really the game corners
were known for one thing being a
glorified casino yeah you could spend
in-game money to acquire coins to then
bet on the slot machines next to npcs to
then use your winnings for everything
from pokemon to rare and powerful tms
the game corner appeared in gens 2 3 and
4 but with pokemon platinum things got a
little weird specifically for south
korea and europe around this time onward
anti-gambling laws in those countries
grew more strict the rating systems were
no longer going to give pokemon a
kid-friendly rating so to help avoid any
raiding above an e the casinos were
removed from future games including the
gen 2 and 3 remakes
yeah whooper is based on a real life
animal you'd think most pokemon are
right for example butterfree and
beedrill are based on their obvious
insect in real life counterparts but
still things get strange when you have
water tortoises like blastoise with
literal water cannons however whooper is
based on the water-based salamander
called an axolotl straight up who would
have guessed
so gen 2 actually had a demo that not a
lot of folks remember there's sparse
footage of it online but one of the
cooler concepts is that the protagonist
of gen 2 gold actually had a skateboard
instead of a bike the footage shows gold
clipping through various map parts which
is clearly a bug but the interesting
thing is that he's also popping ollies
on the skateboard potentially meant to
be able to jump back up from ledges or
to reach hard to obtain spaces of course
the skateboard never made it to the
final cut and instead we got the gen 1
standard bike that players were
accustomed to funny enough later on in
the ruby sapphire versions we see the
acro bike which lets you pop wheelies
and hop around so the inspiration for
having spots that you could only reach
with the key item was kind of always
there the skateboard also actually has a
canonical tie-in as gold is shown riding
a skateboard in the pokemon manga
alright so this one was my favorite
because of just how bonkers it was and
just how ridiculous at the time but it's
absolutely true and newer pokemon fans
you guys might not be aware of it but in
the pokemon anime an episode was banned
for giving nearly 700 japanese kids
seizures yeah in the episode in question
pikachu uses a thunderbolt on a bunch of
missiles from a porygon that when they
collided caused an incredibly rapid
strobe effect of red and blue lights
flashing in a dizzying manner almost
immediately viewers at home reported
headaches nausea and full-on seizures
that required hospitalization almost
recklessly even more viewers had
seizures later when newscasts literally
replayed the scene during their
broadcast when reporting on the seizures
which you'd think they'd know better but
here we are just doesn't get more ironic
than that thankfully the episode was
pulled from airwaves almost immediately
and has never been broadcast again
alright so there's 10 things you didn't
know about pokemon or probably didn't
maybe you knew all of this already and
are super smart or something i don't
know pokemon legends rcs is rapidly
approaching though and we're excited for
the game coming so soon if you're a
veteran pokemon fan let me know in the
comments your best pokemon trivia that
fans might not know and if you're new to
the series let me know if there's
anything you're excited about for
pokemon be sure to check out our
upcoming legends rcs videos and
subscribe to gamespot for all things
gaming until next time
[Music]
you